so what's the deal breaker
the deal breaker is certain like
certainly you know disrespect
continuous disrespect would be one uh
first and foremost
uh infidelity let's just stop on the
disrespect
because i wanted to deal with that's a
good one right when when she doesn't
respect you so
what what is what is the actionable
advice to men out there when it comes to
they're in an ltr whether they're living
together or not or they're married or
something like that
and she clearly doesn't respect him um
i've seen women do this usually in
social gatherings around family and it's
like to try to disparage him as if to
try to
have the upper hand to like gain you
know get some frame
in the relationship dynamic um
what is the go-to mechanism to deal with
disrespect for you guys so
go ahead cool i'll start then oh ryan
yeah right well that really yeah it
depends on the matter of disrespect some
guys that's at home
shoots them down for sex private stuff
right in that case it's boundaries
but it's very consistent boundary
enforcement pull your affection
pull your attention pull your commitment
commencement with the boundaries you
crossed
in this case it's disrespect some guys
really don't care she can yell at me all
she wants to but if she puts out at the
end of the day good
other guys are like i don't want to hear
an unkind word
pick where you want the other ones that
you're talking about that are kind of a
little more malicious are ones in public
like that
i'd argue the problem there
isn't even so much that she's
disrespecting you even though that is a
problem
it's the problem in the same way that
parenting is a problem how parents have
to have i know you guys know this you
have kids
a unified friend right if mom says
something dad backs her up and then you
guys sort it out in private or if
dad says something mom backs it up when
you start breaking team like that it
sends a very strong signal to everybody
that you guys are can i swear yeah of
course
okay basically the two of you are a
piece of [ __ ] couple
piece of [ __ ] yeah so normally what you
do and
i've had like every guy will have to do
this at some point you just kind of take
your girl aside it's like hey
you know that's not on and if they
continue to pull it you know thank you
very much i love
having you over for the barbecue i have
to go home now and then you just leave
and that's the same thing and then you
realize what you can expect so if she
disrespects you in front of people
you're not taking her out anymore she
just lost all those privileges
if she does it in private i mean
sometimes guys would have it where their
girl was
fairly [ __ ] disrespectful and they
would literally
drive out to like a walmart parking lot
just park the car start up a candle and
read
rational mail or robert glover and i
know it sounds stupid it's like oh why
would you demean yourself like that to
go in the parking lot and read
a book it's like she doesn't know what
you're doing all you know
you're doing is yet you're establishing
that your presence
isn't unconditional and yeah it sounds
stupid but at the very least
girls hate being alone and the beauty of
this effect is
if they actually do value you you'll
notice changes
and if they don't value you you're not
going to notice changes but either way
you're going to know where you stand
do you know yeah that's one of the
things that i've talked about a few
times is
is women have to understand that they're
replaceable you'd have to say like but
[ __ ] like you're irreplaceable i can
get rid of you at any time but you know
by way of your actions by the way you
live your life by the way that you
enforce boundaries like ryan just
explain like go to the parking lot read
a book if you have to whatever
she needs to understand that concept
yeah people
they they will only treat you as as much
as you'll tolerate though
that's what a lot of guys they they get
in the relationship and they don't want
to lose a relationship
so they start tolerating things that
they shouldn't tolerate when you remove
your effort
and your time that sends that message
and i
do that without saying anything you know
just look at her and say all right hey
can you uh give her ride home all right
cool
and then you walk away right
that's a great example you know really
and then let her
try to pine after you to figure it out
it's up to her to figure it out
now up to you to explain to her see when
you explain to somebody
who is pining for who at that point
who's demonstrating that they're
the better in this relationship what
message are you sending to her
hypergamous brain if you're going
now sit down let me explain to you why
you shouldn't say
that my dick is small in front of all
these people you know or whatever she
said i'm trying that right now
you know you know like it's like like
you you know when you do that you're
trying to you know
show her that you know you're trying
you're the one trying to bring her in it
needs to be the other way around
right so you just remove your time your
attention your energy and effort and
that stays removed and you continue to
move along that path
until she realizes holy [ __ ] this is
going to end if this keeps going
it's kind of like playing chicken you
know and you have to win that game every
single time
and you don't deal with little stupid
things but like disrespect would be a
bigger thing for sure
you can't tolerate that um i would say
that
and just to tag something onto what ryan
was saying is that
uh private disrespect becomes public
disrespect
so when when you begin to be okay
with with her with with her behavior
because we're talking about behavior
right here
um that's because disrespect is a
behavior but it's also motivated by
something that's that's coming from up
here as well so
i think understanding why she is
incentivized or why
what is motivating that behavior is more
important than actual behavior itself
but when you are okay with that
disrespect
then that translates into it privately
then it becomes okay
to fight with you in public right then
it becomes okay for her to
toss in the uh occasional kind of like
you know
eye roll or oh boy of this this guy you
know that kind of stuff
after a while and you and i've seen
women do this before
um when they're with their girlfriends
they're someone different
than they are when they're with you and
her girlfriends are with you
and with the family or with you and
something else so they become something
different in different social settings
so
if she feels like she has to sort of be
the she has to
you know find her her place in the
pecking order amongst her girlfriends
and her other girlfriends and i see this
all the time other girlfriends
are nagging or they're berating their
husband's
pride and that's a private because
you're not involved in this there's a
private
disrespect amongst your friends then
that gradually
you know like death by a thousand paper
cuts it becomes something a little bit
more and more and more until you
are you suddenly now you're working on
your relationship and it's a
relationships are hard work and and
you're trying you're on the back foot
right and now you're trying to climb
back up the ladder that you thought you
were at the top of already
and a lot of guys when they get to that
point they don't realize
the series of events that happened prior
to them getting to that point
so when you got a guy who is you you
guys probably hear this all the time
like guys will say like
if they're married or they're in an ltr
of some sort so they'll go
roll i lost the frame how do i get the
frame back you know i was so alpha when
i was
26 and now i'm 31 and i lost the frame
and i'm bait all of a sudden she thinks
i'm a beta
is can you can i ever go back and i'm
like okay
let's rewind everything back to when you
were 25 and you were dating
and and let's let's look at what hap the
series of events that happened because
again
it's death by a thousand paper cuts and
if the things you will accept
in private will end up becoming the
disrespect you'll exp you will
accept when it is in public so those are
things to watch out for and then how do
you
how do you guard against them and like
paul was saying sometimes it might be as
simple as
staying silent having that look right um
when your
silence inspires more dread than
anything you could say
that's when you're alpha when when you
are not saying a damn thing
and she's like she's like oh [ __ ] i know
i [ __ ] up
with that that's what you're looking for
you're looking for that organic
innate in insight that she goes okay i
just stepped over
have you guys in each one of you have
girlfriends or have had girlfriends or
have a wife or
cohabitating right um have you ever had
them apologize to you
for something for an infraction that
they did that you didn't like you didn't
act pissy you didn't act
like uh yeah yeah anything like that
they
they offered you an apology for their
behavior or for whatever it was that
they were doing
um organically of course yeah yeah all
the time yeah all the time
that's that's a requirement most guys
will never get that
yeah really true it's very true i want
to share a story about
private disrespect and why it's
important to act immediately
i think i might have mentioned this
before but in my 20s i was i was um
i was going out to get groceries and i
was dating this girl and she was coming
with me at the time
um i was 23 or something like that at
the time and she's chirping in my ear
the whole time about
how um she was doing the typical
comparing
your uh worst to somebody else's best
you know like one of her girlfriend's
boyfriends would spend money on
something or take her to a certain event
or whatever right and it was like blah
blah blah chirp
chirp and i'm driving this um 1990
suzuki swift gti like for me that was a
cool car at the time
i was poor as [ __ ] but i knew how to
drive it and squeeze 100 of the car
and as soon as she said because you're
cheap
i was like excuse me i grabbed the top
of the steering wheel i
reefed it 180 degrees i crossed four
lanes over
the back wheel probably came up you know
cocked up like a cocker spaniel
and i zipped the car home the whole time
she's like oh i'm scared what are you
doing you know slow down and all this
kind of [ __ ]
it wasn't far from the house i get to
the house i reach over
i open the door i go get the [ __ ] out
she gets out of the car
you know still still tripped me all
scared like why are you doing this to us
and blah blah i grabbed the door i
closed it i just [ __ ] drove off
she knew exactly why i turned around
because i did it as soon as she called
me cheap
yeah 15 minutes later when i'm at the
grocery store
i'm just pushing my buggy down the aisle
throwing some [ __ ] in i get a tap on my
shoulder
you don't get that in a grocery store i
turned around it was her
i'm so sorry i shouldn't have said that
can we talk about this blah blah blah
and all that kind of [ __ ]
that's how you deal with disrespect
that's how you maintain the frame so you
never get to a position where
she's not banging you
you